sink your teeth into shark week it kicks
off this sunday on the discovery channel
check out this year's all-star lineup
will smith
snoop dogg mike tyson my guy shaquille
o'neal
they all take part in this summer tv
staple
so we had to check in with shaq because
apparently he did not learn his lesson
from the last time first time i went in
i trained it was cool
then when the shark got in the cage i
panicked
wait luckily for the elbow i elbowed him
in his mouth when he tried to bite me
why after what happened the first time
do you want to go back and swim with a
shark
this time they kind of tricked me they
said we want you to swim with a whale
shark
do they have teeth we have really small
trees okay
really small like how many how many
small do you like 300.
what do whales eat seals and if you put
me in a
in a black get a black swimsuit i look
like a big black seal
cecile o'neal that's my nickname in the
water
next year they're talking about me doing
something with
the great whites in south africa
as long as they got me a cage where the
damn entrance is regulated because see
whoever built that cage last year should
be fired
this time i'm gonna i'm gonna make sure
that the cage is real tight
then the crazy thing there's only one
thing left i have to do and but you have
to do it with me
what's that that's skydiving no no no
come on
come on bro the reason why i need you up
there because if something happens to my
parachute i'm gonna just fly right next
to you
and just hold on to you
if i go down you go down with me brother
shaq is all about big life moments
including this one
honoring kobe i said kobe
there's no iron team and kobe said i
know but there's an emmy in there
i gotta actually got a shrine in my
house that i put up would you like to
see it
yeah i love it see the shrine i put up
in my living room
so definitely think about them every day
and you know the world is doing a great
job of keeping them alive
have you had a chance to talk to vanessa
and how's she doing
i haven't had a chance to talk to her
but hopefully she knows that
you know my family will open up our arms
to her
hopefully her daughters will call me
uncle shaq like my kids called kobe
uncle colby even though he's not with us
he will always be with us
you